morning hey mercedes what's going on
this morning
good morning sherry as we enter the fall
and thanksgiving season you might
already be planning that feast in your
head well if you want to make a side of
corn from scratch what is the easiest
way to remove it from the cob take a
look
okay so i'm doing this to show a few
people who had a couple questions
creative scraps posted this life hack on
tick tock using a small cone and a bunt
cake pan to get off all those kernels
all you gotta do is turn the pan upside
down and then force each cob into the
hole it rips all the kernels right off
why haven't we been doing this all of
our lives that is genius this is an
amazing hat i love it isn't it it is
now
meanwhile some customers at a wisconsin
mcdonald's literally had a cow about an
unexpected guest waiting in the
drive-thru line jessica nelson told up
upi that she first thought the cow
wasn't real but quickly realized
that it was it turns out the cow belongs
to the driver of that car bernie who
wanted to grab some grub after winning
the bull vine at a local state fair so
let's take the cows in for a ride i
guess okay wait a minute so they were
going through mcdonald's
yes okay
first of all the cow said
when you got me you said we'd eat more
chicken
and i thought we were going for
chick-fil-a so so what is the deal with
mickey d's
that's kind of cruel right i think wait
a second
this is a burger joint you never said we
were gonna do that
i'm telling you between the cows and the
corn i think we've got our next few
meals set really oh my goodness that
poor little cow look at the menu going
wait a minute is that one of my
relatives this is not right
oh
i'm trying that corn trick that is the
coolest and the smartest thing i think
i've ever seen
i mean i i think of who thought of that
who decided hey let's try this but it's
genius and yep i'm trying it too i just
wanted to share that with everyone
could put green giant out of business
you know all those can
accord
all right mercedes thank you so much
those are fun